[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and finally the
fans have gotten what they wanted in
regards to the sonic movie now if you've
been following the channel you've seen
that there's been huge outcry over the
design of the character in his new solo
movie with pretty much the entire
internet slamming how he looks and it
doesn't seem like anybody was happy
about it except for this one guy on my
video right they actually deleted their
comments so I can't find it but they
were they wrote an essay about how good
it was and how this was perfectly
fitting to the movie and its tone and I
just replied do you work for Paramount
and they deleted their comment so
everyone except that guy everyone hated
it I mean the guy looked more like Sonic
than Sonic does this pretty much began
an uprising and there were hundreds of
beams that sprang forth from this with
pretty much everyone doing a better job
than the actual designers you do not
want to know what tail to look like well
anyway bad news travels fast and when
you have so many investors and projects
like this they obviously want a huge
return on their money so no doubt
they'll have been putting pressure on
Paramount to fix this this caused the
director to release the following
statement thank you for you to book I
can't do the voice up thank you for your
support and the criticism the message is
loud and clear you aren't happy with the
design and you want changes it's going
to happen
everyone at Paramount and Sega a fully
committed to making this character the
best he can be hashtag sonic movie
hashtag gotta fix this fast
yep you really do cuz you've only got
till November to get this done hashtag
gotta fix his face
I might obeyed that bill well done guys
we did it
sonic is now going to be the best
version of himself
hashtag Jim spiration hashtag
thinspiration it's crazy how much the
studio are actually willing to put money
into this as if you like me then you
probably think that there's other parts
of this movie that need fixing too with
a sledgehammer just burn it just burn
every copy I was actually kind of
interested to see if people would
eventually come around to this idea of
Sonic as we saw with Aladdin I was huge
outcry over Will Smith's genie but
slowly more and more people got on board
with it now this puts the studio in a
strange position because there are
several really good designs already
floating about on the internet but they
can't exactly take those exact ones and
make them as it would probably cause
some conflicts I really hope that they
just hire back the same designers and
make it even worse because I actually
think the bigger the trainwreck that the
movie is the better it will be for
publicity we've already had one of the
best movies ever made this year with a
vendor's endgame so why not one of the
worst it would be great it would bring
balance to the universe and I've
actually got to see it if they just kept
it terrible but now if they fix it it's
probably just gonna be a mediocre mess
so I probably won't this brings up the
question that should they fix the rest
of this movie like if they have the
power to do this why not just CGI Chris
Pratt back into it as he was originally
meant to be there and James Marsden is
probably good that he's gonna be in
another bomb it seems like a nice guy I
don't want the guy at being a bad movie
just fix your face Sonic and everything
I'll be fine
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and if you wanted a train wreck
or if you're happy with what they're
gonna do comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then make
sure you check out my original reaction
to the trailer which will be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who were mad into movies so if that's
the kind of thing you like it's
scribe thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you